you have to develop that act and like
you said the the fundamentals of all
comedy is based on the one and two liner
joke mmm when you can master that then
your stories automatically become
funnier because what is a story made up
of sentences every sentence is a setup
gives you an opportunity to now treat
that like a 1 & 2 liner come up with a
quick quip or two or three and then then
continue with the story so if you're
writing the story you can go back
through your story and go sentence by
sentence by sentence Sid Caesar said a
joke is a sentence with a curlicue what
is every story it's made up of sentences
so if you go up and take each sentence
and can tag on top each one with
something or maybe not each one every
third one and then now you have a bit
that's humorous overall which you have
jokes on the way too big to the big joke
so that's you know tags and toppers is
the way you get more laughs per minute
you know and it's writing the story not
trying to be funny right write it as is
and then go back through and start -
yeah the intent is to get the let me
tell you about the arc of this story
right so it has the five elements of
story setting theme plot character
conflict and then you have and then so
you're telling the story the who what
where why when and how the moral arc and
all this stuff the moral of story is and
then so you have this great story and
then you but you want to it goes on
forever
with no laughs but you can use technique
to drop it in you know one of the
techniques is ask each sentence three
questions one is there a double entendre
play so is there a word that has an
implied meaning I can possibly turn to a
comedic meaning in this sentence just to
get a quick quip you know I came home
from work last night my one you know
it's the night before my wife was
scheduled for c-section so I come home
from a gig and she's laying on the couch
watching TV I said hey babe how you
feeling she says I'm having some gas
pains I say I said well everyone is it's
like five bucks a gallon but and I
continue with the story right it's just
a quick quip on the way to the bigger
story and so I continued to tell the
story but every line gives you something
you can play with then if there isn't a
double entendre play you can say are
there two dissimilar ideas converging
here so I can do an incongruity joke
with this
so if there's nothing if that's not
available
then you could say is there an
assumption in this setup that I can
shatter teach them I assume I'm home I'm
teaching my daughter how to tie her
shoes you know which is weird Trisha 17
and you know you just a quick quick
break this way to the big joke so it's
adding more stuff and that's just three
structures then if you add cliche
reformations you force an analogy in
there
that's how bill burr builds entire
actors through analogy is Mike's taking
two dissimilar ideas and saying they're
similar which sets to the audience an
illogical equation my girlfriend's like
a smartphone huh right they're asking
they're sitting there with tension now
saying solve that how is that true I'm
curious and we'll all you do is solve
for true and the secret is it's got to
be true for us smartphone all by itself
or a pearl friend all by itself because
if you had it if it if the verbage that
you come up with as the tie-in doesn't
match a person or a girlfriend then it's
not gonna work
it sounds forced it's gonna be odd but
if you say my ex like I say my ex it
builds more of an antagonistic situation
I said my ex is like a smartphone at any
given time I can usually find her at at
least one bar mm-hm and that's what a
coincidence that's so true but that fits
for a person or a smartphone one bar
being the signal of course right so but
that's just by listing everything
smartphone so it's gonna ask how do you
find the connection between the income
group yes so you take basically take if
I decide to use smart phones say if I
want to use sometimes in this case what
I'm doing is I'm taking an element and
comparing it to my wife rather than find
traits about my wife and then finding
the element to relate it to like if I my
ex-wife was a alcoholic right so I said
so I you I played on that angle I said
what else is alcoholic what else is
alcoholic kind of funny cars funny cars
are alcohol fueled so if I say might
want my ex-wife yeah my ex-wife she's
alcohol she's like a
funny car alcohol-fueled now I have a
quick joke there but I'm working the
other approach to it the alternate
approach finding what is she like and
then finding something to relate her to
this way I'm taking any element and
comparing it to my ex-wife and then
listing everything I can think about
using subcategories of people places
things words phrases cliches events and
and I'll write that down people places
things words phrases cliches events
every single time I do a list to remind
myself because when you're so close to
it you're going through the list
sometimes you just get too heady and
I'll go on into any cliches here what do
people say when they say this what
people are involved in smart from dude
can you hear me now that guy you know
and I'll just write down everything I
can about a smartphone what else in
smartphone in the minutia the signal
what about the signal the bars hey what
are some of the phrases hey my phone's
only had two bars bar as bar is double
entendre that's a bar could be a
drinking establishment fits from my
ex-wife
mics on my ex-wife's like a smartphone
you know at any given time I can usually
find her at least one bar same phrase
fits for phone see thanks a lot for
watching this video if you love comedy
as much as we do here at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath averse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips and
stop sucking at comedy go ahead click it